Iran has enormous pent-up demand for
modernization of its infrastructure
roads water and power lines as well as
housing badly need to be upgraded after
more than a decade of isolation the
decay is visible for the Iranian Chamber
of Commerce the biggest headache is
obsolete manufacturing plants that means
companies are not able to compete in the
global market but it's an opportunity
for foreign investors the country has a
very deep problems with the environment
and water and we must do something very
fast about it
meanwhile there's a lot of opportunities
here a very good and skilled manpower
very good educated people here these
German made machines packed cheese
slices at one of Iran's biggest dairies
the plant has been in operation for
about 15 years it's been difficult to
keep plants like this going even if they
didn't come under the international
embargo due to the sanctions Iran was
cut off from the global funds transfer
system that made it almost impossible to
purchase expensive equipment and spare
parts Emira so today Regional Director
of German manufacturer multi vac
continued to provide Iranian customers
with parts for their aging machines
despite the sanctions providing this
service didn't make any money for multi
vak but so today thinks his company has
good chances to win back its old
customers and gain some new ones we
believe in future of Iranian market
Iran is a big population more than 75
million population young generation so
many food factories good quality food
factories that are located in here
and they look after quality equipment
before the sanctions went into effect
Germany was Iran's biggest trading
partner and German products have
retained their good reputation there the
country is a leader in the question of
technology machinery and industry and
those are the areas that we are in need
in while there is a very good and long
history of cooperation with between the
companies of two nations but there's
tough competition but Jacques Le Derry
gets plenty of offers from Chinese and
Turkish companies they've been quick to
fill the gaps when German suppliers had
to bow out due to the sanctions